our next presenter is only 12 years old
and has already won an Academy Award for
Best Supporting Actress you know when I
was 12 I could drink a gallon of root
beer in under a minute thank you here
now to present the Academy Award for
Best Supporting Actor please welcome
Anna Paquin
thank you now let's get serious grown-up
movie makers had to pick one of five
accomplished actors for best performance
and a supporting role the nominees are
samuel l.jackson perfection Martin
Landau in Midwood chairs Coleman Terry
and bullets over Broadway Paul Scofield
and quiz show Gary Sinise and Cyrus Cohn
and we Oscar goes to Martin Landau and
Edwards
Oh
my god what a night what a life what a
moment what everything I I talked to I
talked to Jim Burton today in New York
and I want to finish a conversation
thanks to him for giving me the part of
my life
no Cates don't don't put music on
because of its a Mission Impossible
theme
I'll get very angry Larry and Scott
thanks for the great script the Disney
people for well for doing it in the
first place you know I think everyone
who saw the movies in this room tonight
and thank you for the for their support
Johnny Depp
thank you for your talent your
professionalism your goodness a great
cast down the line gave me a chance to
work with my daughter for the first time
Rick V and Yolanda who have already won
an award tonight for making it all
possible for me the members of the press
particularly rod Lori who is my number
one fan of the present has been an avid
supporter for years my my team of
long-standing Peter Bennett Stan Bush L
Mike Monaco's my agents who were here
tonight for at Westheimer Ames pushing
my gifted daughter Suzy and Juliet Lando
my best friend Gretchen Becker who's
here is talented my sister Connie who is
doing battle with an with leukemia right
now and winning that battle
the Academy the actors who I loved who
nominated me the entire membership let's
keep the NEA funded and healthy artists
need encouragement